much rights in doing a typical pitch to
a journalist or media channel seems
boring have you ever done something
unusual or creative to get coverage from
the media um so I agree that sometimes
it can get boring and if you think about
it I think from the perspective of the
reporters that you're reaching out to
right they are probably receiving
hundreds if not thousands of media
pitches emails a day with story ideas
that quite honestly me talk to reporters
they say the majority of them are junk
so why not you know to your point make
it a little bit more creative something
that will grab their attention so one
example that I have is last week was
national customer service week I don't
know if you guys are familiar with it
but here a pepper we are a leader or
we're bill leader in the ESP space for
our customer solutions department right
we're known for having outstanding
customer solutions so we basically we
took national customer service week and
the fact that we are a leader for
customer service in our space and we
turned that into basically a media idea
things that we can share on our blogs
and things like that but to bring some
life to the story what we did was create
a video and we created a video that
showed our CEO and our COO talking about
why we're a leader in customers in
customer service what we do here what
customer service means here at a weber
and then we also showed our CEO and our
co l in the customer solutions
department taking calls assisting
customers and things like that and so
what i did was i use that for my media
pitching so it wasn't just hey national
customer service week is this week where
a leader in customer service so consider
an article from us no it's those things
plus here let me show you let me bring
it to life for you you know and so
that's another way that just kind of mix
things up for them and get a little bit
creative another thing that I would also
recommend speaking to the point of not
just a basic couple sentence email
create some visuals create infographics
create videos like we said also if you
have data to back up where you're saying
or to support where you are saying
journalist love data so you know get
creative with what
with how you go about things and what
you send to them to bring a story to
life for them if it's helping them do
their job so I totally agree that
getting creative is something that you
should consider yeah when looking at
that question I think of PT Barnum who
used to have a circus and he answered an
elephant to plow his fields just because
the art is about PT Barnum that's like a
pig i right thing I love PT for now may
I study up I study up I remember
learning about it so ok well for those
who don't know the story there should be
this train ride that would go in and and
people would look at the train and they
see this elephant plowing a field and it
just caused he was a big he was all
about the curiosity and people would
then want to know like what's happening
here and he would always milk as much as
he could from publicity but never the
typical like boring pitches is always
something different I think the modern
day is like Richard Branson who drives
to New York City on a tank and like jet
skis in and repels down buildings and he
makes big events out of things I haven't
done anything anywhere close to that I'm
I think and mostly fighting are super
boring and tame in comparison but there
was a guest room to improve their the
closest thing that I've done that was
different was when I was just getting
started this business I was what 22
years old and I felt like I was a
no-name we did have a lot of credibility
I was young people would look at me like
what I'm gonna learn from this guy who's
too young so I put together what I call
the guide to professional success and I
contacted a whole bunch of really
well-known font leaders like Anthony
Robbins and brian tracy and Zig Ziglar
and kind of the leaders at the time and
got I said here I want to create this
guy professional success I'm gonna have
it as a free download up my website can
i use this article and it was an article
they had written from their newsletter
online somewhere and i got permission
from them to be able to use that article
and i combine all of the articles
together and then i added mine in there
as well so there's like evan with all of
these big names and so it started adding
kind of more instant credibility and
people in the media picked up on it
because it was kind of
different so they're interested in
reading it sharing it and it got me my
first kind of like hint of excitement
from the media okay I think overall I'm
pretty boring I name is a good challenge
it's a good challenge much to do
something they need to write a tank
through Toronto or something I think
bigger bungee jump from the CN tower to
support entrepreneurs or something